حركه فتح هي صاحبه الرصاصه الاولى في
النضال
الفلسطيني ومنظمه التحرير التي تشكل فتح
اكبر فصائلها هي الممثل الشرعي والوحيد
للشعب الفلسطيني كل ذلك معروف ولامر ما
اعاده الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس الى
الواجهه في اخر ايام المؤتمر السابع لحركه
فتح مناسبه انتخب فيها اعضاء اللجنه
المركزيه وهي بمثابه جهاز تنفيذي في
الحركه واعضاء المجلس الوطني الجهه
التشريعيه فيها وجوه جديده واخرى اقل جده
اختارها الفتحاويين في هذا المؤتمر الذي
لم تعدم نتائجه المنتقدين نتابع التفاصيل
مع محمد
ابراهيم سته ايام حافله بالخطابات
والمداولات استغرقتها اعمال المؤتمر العام
السابع لحركه فتح وافضت الى انتخابات
اعضاء المجلس الثوري واللجنه
المركزيه حظي المؤتمر الذي يعقد للمره
الثانيه في الداخل الفلسطيني
بحضور غير مسبوق لممثلين عرب واجانب بعد
تصويت اليوم الاخير للمؤتمر اظهرت النتائج
فوز القيادي الاسير مروان البرغوثي بتجديد
عضويته في اللجنه المركزيه بغالب ساحقه من
الاصوات ومن بين الاسماء الفائزه الاخرى
برز اسم اللواء جبريل رجوب مؤسس جهاز
الامن الوقائي في الضفه وصائب عريقات امين
سر لجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير وعزام
الاحمد مسؤول ملف المصالحه مع حركه حماس
والقياده
ناصر القدوه ابو عباس زكي ومن بين الوجوه
التي دخلت اللجنه المركزيه للمره الاولى
الحاج اسماعيل جبر واحمد حلس وصبري صيدم
وروحي فتوح ودلال سلامه وسمير الرفاعي
فيما منحت العضويه الفخريه الدائمه لفاروق
القدومي وسليم الزعنون وابو ماهر غنيم وهم
من مؤسسي حركه فتح كان لافتا ان القائمه
خلت من اسماء معروفه في تاريخ الحركه مثل
احمد قريع احد مهندسي اتفاقات اوسلو
والطيب عبد الرحيم وهو احد مؤسسي السلطه
الفلسطينيه ونبيل شعث مسؤول العلاقات
الخارجيه في الحركه ونبيل عمرو احد
المسؤولين الباردين في مرحله الزعيم
الفلسطيني الراحل ياسر عرفات ورغم الزخم
الذي شهده طيله ايام انعقاده فان المؤتمر
لم يسلم من الانتقادات لا سما طريقه
الانتخاب والترشح والتعيينات وصولا الى ما
اعتبر تهميشا لممثلي شتات يرى خصوم عباس
ومنتقد المؤتمر ان النتائج شكلت مؤشرا على
اعاده ترتيب البيت الداخلي في الحركه بما
يهواه الرئيس عباس وحلفائه في مقابل
استبعاد من يوصفون بالمتجر حين اي
الموالين القيادي المفصول محمد دحلان لكن
بعيدا عن الانقسام التنظيمي والخلافات
الداخليه للحركه التي تعتبروا العمود
الفقري للنضال الوطني الفلسطيني منذ نصف
قرن فان منتقدي اعمال مؤتمرها السابع
بداوا يتحدثون عن اخفاقه في اجتراح برامج
سياسيه لمواجهه المازق التاريخي الذي وصل
فيه القضيه الفلسطينيه بعد نحو عقدين من
عمليه السلام مع اسرائيل الى طريق مسدود
وفي نظر هؤلاء لن تكون التسويات التنظيميه
والانتخاب بكافيه لمواجهه استحقاقات اليوم
التالي بل استحقاقات اللحظه الراهنه
بالمعنى الوطني والتي ياتي في مقدمتها
كيفيه مواجهه العدوان الاسرائيلي المستمر
ومواصله قضمه لفرص اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه بالاستيطان
والتهويد ينضموا الينا من رام الله اللواء
جبريل رجوب عضو اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
ومن عمان معين الطاهر الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الفلسطيني لواء جبريل الرجوب اهلا
وسهلا بك ومبروك ما ابرز ما خرج به مؤتمر
فتح هذا العام غير انه انتخبك ا اهلين
اهلا
بك يعني شو هذا سؤال يعني بعتقد تسطيح
للامور ايش انتخبني وما انتخبني ي حركه
عريقه النضال الفلسطيني فاتحه عادت لا يا
الله يبارك فيك مش غير انه انتخبني يعني
شو يعني بعدين انا مش جاب الفني كمان يعني
انا امبارح قبل 48 سنه بالضبط انا اول مره
سجنت اسرائيل وقعدت 17 سنه يعني
بالسجن خنا شويه يعني
هذ يا سيدتي هذا اهم مؤتمر بتعقد حركه فتح
في تاريخها لسببين السبب الاول انه حقيقه
صار في فلسطين ويمكن المره الثانيه بس
الاهم من ذلك انه لاول مره نحن بنقدر نجيب
الشتات
والداخل المحافظات الشماليه والجنوبيه تحت
سقف واحد وانا بقول انه رام الله ارادتها
حره ورام الله تقرر ما ترى فيه مصلحه
لشعبنا
ولقضاء خرج ببرنامج سياسي خرج بتوصيات
تنظيميه وجزء من اعمال المؤتمر انه هو
انتخب قيادي ولكن كمان رفع م مجموعه من
التوصيات لها علاقه باعاده هيكله الحركه
ومؤسساتها واجهزتها بحيث انها تستوعب كل
ابناء الحركه ويتم تسكينهم في مواقع
تنظيميه في كل العالم بالنسبه للبرنامج
السياسي اللي هو برنامج الاجماع الوطني
اللي علاقه باقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
المستقله كامله السياده وفق قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه الان في هناك استحقاقات ل
علاقه بالاصلاح ان كان في حركه فتح و وان
كان في المنظمه وان كان في السلطه برضه هي
نقشت في في المؤتمر وفي توصيات وفي اوراق
اقرت ونحن ابتداء من بكره رح نبدا بورش
عمل وحده لها علاقه بفتح والنهوض فيها
وسلاح كل ال القضايا اللي اوصى فيها
المؤتمر كما قلت بما في ذلك اعاده صياغه
النظام الموضوع الاخر له علاقه بالوحده
الوطنيه
وبالمصنع يعني استقبلنا اثناء المؤتمر
رساله من الاخ خالد مشعل رساله فيها درجه
عاليه من المسؤوليه الوطنيه قدرنا
المبادره
وبنعترف المصالحه لكن قبل ذلك اتوقف مع
ضيفي من عمان معين الطاهر اسالك سيد معين
الطاهر بان هنالك
المنتقدون هنالك من انتقد هذا المؤتمر راى
انه لم يخرج ببرنامج سياسي ولم يقدم حلا
للازمه التي تقع فيها حاليا القضيه
الفلسطينيه في التعامل مع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعدما وصلت المفاوضات الى طريق
مسدود ما رايك بمن انتقد هذه النقطه
بالتحديد نعم انا في الحقيقه خالف الاخ
جبريل في رؤيته للبرنامج السياسي انا
اعتقد ان هذا المؤتمر قد سجل تراجعا كبيرا
على صعيد البرنامج السياسي واسمحوا لي ان
اقرا هنا
من المؤتمر طبعا اقر ان ما جاء في خطاب
السيد الرئيس محمود عباس هو يمثل البرنامج
السياسي للمؤتمر البند الاول قال ان
السلام هو الستراتيجي هو الاستراتيجيه
الفلسطينيه النقطه الخطره هي في البند
الثاني الذي يتحدث عن انهاء الاحتلال
العسكري الاسرائيلي لارض دوله فلسطين
والذي بدا عام
ايه البرنامج السياسي بهذه الطريقه يختصر
الصراع الفلسطيني الصهيوني والصراع العربي
الصهيوني ببدء الاحتلال العسكري في سنه
1967 ربما كان يعني مساغا اكثر ان يقال
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه على الاراضي التي
احتلت سنه 67 ولكن ان يصور الصراع وكانه
ابتدا منذ ذلك التاريخ فهذا يمثل تراجع
كبير نقطه اخرى في في البرنامج السياسي
الحديث عن المقاومه جاء في الفقره الثانيه
عشر وجاء بالمقاومه الشعبيه السلميه
تخيلوا بعد 12 فقره نتحدث عن مقاومه الشعب
الفلسطيني للاحتلال وهي ذات الفقره التي
تتحدث عن المناطق جيم اي المناط المناطق
التي تعج بال بالمستوطنات حتى موضوعه
الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني والحقوق
الغير قابله للتصرف جاءت في الفقره
الرابعه عش وجاءت في من خلال
سياق تضامن ال الجمعيات والمنظمات الدوليه
مع الشعب الفلسطيني وحقوقه الغير قابله
للتصرف اي لم تاتي في اطار المطالبه بهذه
الحقوق لذلك كذلك جاء هذا البرنامج منعزل
بشكل عام عن التاريخ المجيد
لحركه فتح لذلك انا اعتقد في الحقيقه ان
هذا البرنامج السياسي قد سجل نقطه تراجع
اخرى اضافيه لم يسبق ان سجلت في اي من
مؤتمرات فتح السابقه ولا في المؤتمرات
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه منذ اقرار برنامج
النقاط العش في سنه ال ط هذا الانتقاد
سقله الى السيد جبريل رجوب سياده
لواء المؤتمر كما جاء في اجابه ضيفي معين
الطاهر منعزل عن التاريخ المجيد لكم كيف
ترد يعني اولا ما حدا بيقدر يقول يعني
منعزل عن التاريخ يعني احنا طارئين على
النضال الوطني الفلسطيني مع كل احترامي
للي بحكيه الاخ ماهر وهو الاخ معين الطاهر
وهو يعني مناظل وكان قائد كتيبه الجرمق في
حركه فتح وانا بعتقد هي الحركه اللي هي
عمله مجد الشعب الفلسطيني ننا جزء منها
يعني ثلاث ار باعنا ما كل واحد حامل جلو
وز معه يعني احنا مش طارئين ولا نازلين
بالبو
ين الوطن
الفلين معلش مش شخصي كلنا يا ستي يا ستي
يا ستي معلش انا ترتيبي الف حركه انا
ترتيبي على راسي يا استاذ جبريل اتحدث
اتحدث على اتحدث عن البرنامج عن البرنامج
والسيد معين ايضا يتحدث عن البرنامج نحدث
عن شخص شخصات على راسنا يا
ستي يا ستي ما انت بتقول انتم مقطوعين عن
الواقع يعني احنا حركه كان 1400 واحد
وهذول ال 1400 واحد ما هم كمان مناضلين
وكل واحد فيهم جاي من موقع يعني مش جايين
من الانتركونتيننتال يا سيدتي في فرق بين
ما تلاه الاخ ابو مازن من خطاب للعالم
بصفته رئيس للسلطه ورئيس
للمنظمه وانا بعتقد انه ابو مازن بده
يتحدث بلغه العالم عش نكسب العالم لانه
القضيه الفلسطينيه والصراع اللي بيننا
وبين اسرائيل مش بس احنا واياهم كمان احنا
جزء من الاقليم وجزء من
العالم حديثنا بلغه العالم لا يعني انه
احنا تنزلنا عن حقوقنا ما هي لغه العالم
احنا بنقول بدنا دوله فلسطينيه الخطاب
الاخ لغه العالم اللي هي الشرعيه الدوليه
اللي بتقول تقام دوله فلسطينيه في حدود
عام 67 وهذا اللي كمان اجمعوا عليه العرب
وموجود في المبادره العربيه هسه اذا
الموضوع هو موضوع تسجيل كلام وبدنا نرجع
لايام فيصل القاسم انا برايي هذه مش طيب
اريد ان اسالك حتى انتقل الى الملف الاخر
سياده اللواء
العرب هل في ظل تجمد المفاوضات بسبب
استمرار الاحتلال بالاستيطان وتعنته بهذا
الشكل والاعتداء على المقدسات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه وايضا الاعتداء على حقوق
الفلسطينيين هل هل جرت التطرق وباي اسلوب
الى مساله اعاده النظر بالعلاقه مع
الاحتلال هل هنالك استراتيجيه جديده في
التعاطي
معه يا ستي من قرار لا لا لا احنا اخذنا
قرار بالمؤتمر بالاجماع
راح نعمل مراجعه للعلاقه مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي سواء كان العلاقه السياسيه او
الاقتصاديه او الامنيه وهذا موضوع معلن
يعني انا ما بعرف نحن مش بدنا مش فلان قال
وفلان ما قال احنا حركه محترمه وحريصه على
اهدافنا ومبادئنا ومنطلقاتها وما زلنا
متمسكين بما اقر في المؤتمر الاول للحركه
ومجمل التكتيكات لا يمكن ان تبعدنا عن
هدفنا الاستراتيجي اللي له علاقه بالدوله
والتكتيكات اللي لها علاقه بالمقاومه
مقاومه شعبيه ولا كفاح مسلح ولا ولا ولا
المقاومه كمبدا جزءا من عقيدتنا الوطنيه
ويا ستي ما احن مش مانعين حدا ليقاوم ولا
يزحف بدبابات ولا بصواريخ على فلسطين اما
ذا الموضوع موضوع خطاب ما هو اي واحد بحكي
ما شاء اللهع يعني ال الخلا يعني الخلاف
هنا مع حماس على ماذا اذا سلام اسمع يعني
وما مصير ملف المصالحه والوحده الوطنيه
هنا بناء على كلامك هذا طالما غير مانعين
هذا الاسلوب في المقاومه اذا ما ما بناء
على كلامك سيد سياده اللواء ما مصير
المصالحه بعد هذا المؤتمر الذي رحبت به
حماس في كلمه ممثل خالد مشعل في المؤتمر
وانت ايضا الان اشدت بالكلمه ما هو المصير
مصير الوحده الوطنيه لو سمحت انا معلش يا
ستي يا ستي اول شيء انا مش جاي هون عشان
انتقد حماس احنا بنقول لك انه عملوا خطوه
ونحنا رحبنا فيها ونشكرهم عليها وبدنا
نبني عليها بدنا نرجع نقول مقاومه مين
اللي بيقاوم مين بيقاوم انا لا اريد ان
ادخل في هذا الموضوع لانه كمان غزه هي تحت
حكم حماس ومش احنا احنا مش هناك فيا سيدتي
احنا نرى فيما قدم اقدم عليه الاخ خالد
مشعل خط ما بدي اكمل لك يا بنت الحلال
مالك واليوم انت احنا الان نرى في الخطوه
اللي قامت فيها حماس خطوه ايجابيه ومباشره
بعد خلال ايام رح نفتح حوارا جديا له
علاقه بانهاء الانقسام انهاء الانقسام
والذي يبدا باتفاقنا بانهم هم بنه سيطرتهم
بالقوه على على قطاع غزه ونحنا نقر بمبدا
بناء نظام في شراكه سياسيه من خلال عمليه
ديمقراطيه احنا نرى في ذلك اساسا للانطلاق
باتجاه مصالحه وطنيه وباتجاه انهاء هذا
العار اللي كلا متضررين منه الطه سيد معين
الطاهر باعتقادك التحدي الاكبر الان كما
يقال بعد هذا المؤتمر ماذا بعد المؤتمر
التحدي الاكبر هو الوحده الوطنيه
والمصالحه والان خاصه بعد استبعاد من
يصفون بال متجن حين اي الموالين للقيادي
المفصول في فتح محمد دحلان هل هل هل سنرى
فتح قويه جاهزه حاضره معنيه صافيه
للمصالحه مع حماس ولاعاد اللحمه الوطنيه
لفلسطين يعني انا يعني اولا اود ان اوضح
بانني لا انتقد اشخاص انا اتحدث عن برامج
وعندما انتقد برنامج فانا اعتقد ان هذا من
حق اي مواطن فلسطيني ان ينتقد اي برنامج
ثانيا التاريخ فتح مجيد هو ملك لكل
الفتحاويين ولكن هذا لا يعفيها من
مسؤولياتها الحاليه لا يجوز ان نبقى نقول
اننا اول الرصاص واول الحجاره ونحن نسلك
مسار اخر يختلف عن هذا المسار احيانا عوده
الى الى موضوع المؤتمر والى موضوع
المصالحه انا اظن ان المؤتمر قد فشل في
تحقيق مراجعه واول بوادر هذا الفشل كانت
عندما قرر المؤتمر في الجلسه الاولى ان
يبايع ويعيد انتخاب الرئيس محمود م عباس
تصفيقا ليس انتقاصا من قدر الرئيس ولكن
المفروض في هذا المؤتمر وفي اي مؤتمر حزبي
او حركي ان يقوم باجراء عمليه مراجعه
تقييم نقد المسؤول الاول عن السياسه في
المرحله الماضيه كان الرئيس محمود عباس
اذا بايعه المؤتمر وانتخبه من الجلسه
الاولى منذ اللحظه الاولى فمن سيحاسب
المؤتمر من
سينتقدون
ما هي قصه التنسيق الامني ما هو موضوع
اغتيال الشهيد ياسر عرفات من سيسال
المؤتمر ذلك كله اذا كان قد تم مبايعه
الرئيس منذ اللحظات الاولى انا رايي ان
المؤتمر قد قد يعني انهى اعماله منذ تلك
اللحظه في الحقيقه واصبح بعد ذلك وقبل ذلك
مهرجان مهرجان انتخابي لاول مره نشاهد في
حركه فتح ظاهره انتخابات على الفيسبوك
وكان الانتخابات هي ملك للشعب الفلسطيني
كله على كل حال يعني دعينا دعي من ذلك و
عوده الى الى سؤالك مره اخرى انا في
الحقيقه خائف جدا من موضوع المصالحه
الوطنيه مش مش فقط المصالحه مع حماس انا
ما اخشاه في الحقيقه وما احذر منه هو ان
يتم تكرار تجربه المؤتمر السابع لحركه فتح
بسيناريو شبيه في المجلس الوطني الفلسطيني
انا اعتقد ان هذا اذا حدث سيشكل كارثه
حقيقيه وسمس بمنظمه التحرير ك كبيت معنوي
وكيان معنوي للفلسطينيين في كل انحاء
العالم
الحقه تصريحات لعدد كبير عنوانان رئيسيان
اختم معك بسؤال سريع كيف سيكون شكل
العلاقه مع الرباعيه العربيه التي كانت
تدعم دحلان باعتقادك بشكل
سريع سيد معين سؤال الي ولا س معينك سؤال
اوك انا انا انا في
الحقيقه طيب اوكي انا انا في الحقيقه لا
اعتقد ان من حق اي دوله عربيه ان تتدخل في
الشان ال الفلسطيني على الاطلاق الا في
اطار النصيحه وال والتعاون والدعم ق لكنني
في قال احد يمي عل شكن ولكنني في نفس
الوقت انا بعتقد نعم نعم وانا انا اوافق
على ذلك ولكن انا اعتقد في نفس الوقت ان
بعض السياسات التي يمارسها السييد الرئيس
محمود عباس هو بهذه السياسات يضع الحب في
طاحونه محمد دحلان شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان
معين الطاهر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الفلسطيني واشكر من رام الله سيا الل واء
جبريل رجوب عضو اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
اشكرك سيد رجوب في الملف الثاني يسلط
لحبيب الغريبي الضوء على الجدل الدائر في
العراق بشان مشروع الموازنه الذي تجري
مناقشته في البرلمان على وقع شكوى والتظلم
من اكثر من طرف